hey everyone I'm Kristen Gill and you're
watching how to Hollywood and today I
have celebrity makeup artist at TN
Ortega here with me so today we're gonna
be having some fun and recreating a look
I did on Becky G for the my audience
video alright so first off we're gonna
start with a little bit of translucent
powder to protect the skin from any
staining or any fallout from our smoky
look this is also gonna help us bake and
highlight we're gonna do this look with
my new pure pearl palette when I did
Becky's actual video we I actually did
use this so with the fluffy brush and
the color Lola I'm gonna start going
across your lid and depositing color and
I'm gonna take it all the way up to the
crease and just start blending
everything out so we have a nice finish
it was so much fun there's like I mean
Becky's such a little genius with her
with her music video she came up with
the concept of the idea music videos are
actually like my favorite thing to do so
that's where I really get to play and be
creative and is it like a collab or did
she was she like these are like the
looks or did you see her outfit like how
did you come up with what would make up
she's you know she always brings up her
ideas and what she was she thinks and
then I put my input into it and
collaboration collaboration yeah but
she's very open and she's so fun to to
work with you could see how easy these
shades are to blend and the more you put
on the more you build when did you first
meet Becky I met Becky like 3 or 4 years
ago
for this like really early morning show
was my first time working there and she
was there and she was so sweet and her
whole family's super amazing and it cuts
very close to like how my family is so
we clicked like immediately I love that
when you feel like you kind of known
somebody forever okay so with a tighter
brush I'm gonna go in with the same
color and go under your lash line with
the smokey eye it is it's really
important to layer and to diffuse
everything blend everything out to get a
really
seamless finish here ever in doubt just
keep blending that's what I always talk
blender different blend is your friend I
love that so for the my Yoda's video it
was actually not that complicated we
used three simple shades and one was
Lola and now I'm gonna be using Zenon
Zenon and I don't know why but like when
I thought of like this silver tone i was
like Zenon I use this color just right
and the tear duct just taught a little
bit of a highlight so now I'm gonna pick
up my color 3:00 a.m. which is the
blackest darkest shade in my palette
because it's the darkest hour all right
so I'm just gonna be focusing this color
I'm close to the lash line and a little
bit in her crease I'm gonna go with the
little tapered brush and I'm slightly
gonna bring it up to the crease and
we're just trying to add depth and
dimension here it instantly gives you
drama I'm gonna take the same 3m shade
and now we're gonna intensify under your
eyes we're getting into the dark out I
know you see how intense everything is
gone seeing that was three easy shades
which was Lola xenon and 3:00 a.m. the
next step to finishing this eye look is
going in with a really black pencil this
is feline by Mac and we're gonna do
inside your waterline and this is really
just gonna finish the look off yes I'm
just gonna go over it with the same
brush no additional product and just
kind of blend everything together I'm
gonna do a little bit of this pink
Mellon Aid highlight it's kind of like a
blush as as well as a highlight so I'm
gonna do your bottom lashes a little bit
with Revlon's mega multiplier for that
video we did a very thick lash and
clumpy almost but that's what I was
going for yeah so two good coats of
mascara will be perfect for this okay so
baggy had a really nice nude lip to
compliment the eyes we did so we did a
nude lip and I used spice by Mac and I'm
just gonna over draw our lips a little
bit to give it more of a sexy vibe so
Kevin Oh cuando su bien it's my favorite
gloss ever so I'm just gonna apply a
right to your lips it's a very peachy
sexy color and I'm blending the gloss
with a liner
[Music]
[Music]
yes where's your wig I know we're eating
it but uh thank you Jesus in the house
is that thank you guys so much for
watching at en thank you so much for
being here thank you for having me
make sure to LIKE and subscribe to our
YouTube channel and follow at Tien on
social media and we will see you in the
next one bye guys